alors moi j'ai retrouvé beaucoup
d'interviews
yvan attal vous disiez toujours oui mais
alors vous ne couperez pas refaire une
interview oui mais alors je vous demande
simplement de cuire la pâte
j'adore ce film et mais je l'adorent un
point tu peux même pas imaginer
je suis peut-être pas le meilleur
réalisateur du monde mais mais au moins
dans mon film j'ai les meilleurs acteurs
du monde
je n'ai rien contre mon physique mais
mais d'autres non plus d'ailleurs
vous avez quoi l'oreille là je suis né
comme ça
ah bon je crois que c'était je vous dis
la vérité je vous aviez une boucle
d'oreille quelqu'un vous l'avez ratée je
suis très en forme je raconte tout un
baratin comme quoi je serais une femme
et qu'on a mais là je suis né comme ça
ce soir la vérité pas vous faire chier
jeu plaît beaucoup aux femmes
mais où est le problème c'est vrai je
veux beaucoup mais je suis marié je suis
une star chez les gays mais mais je
n'apprécie pas spécialement les
partouzes mai mais c'est parce que je
suis très jaloux l'un dans l'autre
j'aime pas et sandwichs grecs mais dans
une partouze
je suis pour la paix dans le monde mais
c'est pas gagné
bien à temps c'est vrai mais jamais
trois mais j'ai toujours j'ai peur de
mourir mais ça je me soigne j'ai envie
de vous tirer même mais un peu trop de
monde est-ce que tu n'es pas pour faire
une interview mu mais oui mais j'ai joué
dans des films pourris mais mais j'ai
bien l'intention de tourner avec cédric
klapisch
je ne travaille pas pour l'argent mais
mais en tant que personnes d'obédience
judaïque je suis intéressé par tout ce
qu'elle a tout l'aspect financier
évidemment je paie trop d'impôts mais
mais plus on en gagne plus on empanne y
voilà je ne crois pas en dieu mais mais
quand même j'aimerais bien qu'ils
croient en moi elle réagissait sur je
paye trop de risques
sur l'interview d'un autre mec allez
vous avez été en prison
je je je je je t'aime apprécie pas
particulièrement les partouzes mais à
mai mais je ferais bien un petit tour au
bristol
je suis une star chez les gays mais une
star chez les gays moi bien sûr
c'est vrai vous aime bien mais à choisir
je préfère prendre une manette je peux
te fâcher avec toute la communauté la
croix tu crois que il fait que j'avoue
que j'aimerais bien de faire attraper
éventuellement ça arrange les affaires
ou droit élargi raymond et ses boucles
je ne suis pas jaloux mais mais quand
même ça m'ennuierait de savoir que tu as
un mec amaizing quand est ce que j'ai un
mec d'antoine soeur quand on laisse les
semis story ever feel better the mystery
of ok ok on y célèbre hymne single ce
soir une daube et je ne suis pas de
droite mais mais je suis de gauche
j'ai une toute petite vite mais bon
c'est un jeu et visa je me suis jeune
par rapport à wendy c'est vrai il y
avait ce mot le dit que d'autres
batailles de bristol au sapeur de la bac
s commence à s'allonger
elle s'éloigne alors je dors arthur mais
j'aime bien hardi sont aussi à wayne
je bosse qui est un gros con mais ya pas
de m
mais comment vous le savez avec un peu
de chance comme ce que l'écho et si vous
allez faire la promo de son émission il
aura déjà piqué l'interview que je vais
vous faire là alors moi je suis pas sûr
d'aller faire sur l'émission tout de
suite parce que je suis très débordé
mais non seulement je crois qu'il t'a
piqué tes fiches mais il a piqué mailing
j'ai appris ça ouais interview oui mais
[Musique]
arthur je vous demanderai donc de finir
ma phrase tout simplement je m'appelle
arthur en effet mais mais c'est pas mon
vrai prénom à mon vrai prénom c'est
jacques jacques mon vrai prénom c'est
jacques
mais quand j'ai démarré à la radio j'ai
pris arthur parce que ça sonnait mieux
parce que jacques leroy de la radio
jacques et les pirates s'étaient moyens
et j'adore mon prénom ou dans la une des
magazines estelle et jacques le mariage
jacques a dit oui je vais monter sur
scène mais mais c'est pas sûr parce que
si la douleur que j'ai dans le vide
continua monte monte monte je crois que
ça donne encore l'appendicite non non
non c'est lyon me l'enlever j'ai été
opéré de l'appendicite le jour j'ai
rencontré ma femme tu veux croire c'est
très con ça a mis un doigt dans le cul
je connais
le lendemain de sa rencontre à temps
c'est un peu la vraie histoire j'ai fais
un voeu laverie score c'est que j'ai
dîné avec et ce thème c'était notre
premier rendez vous galant mais comment
on pouvait pas être tous les deux selon
étaient chacun accompagnés et un moment
j'ai commencé à avoir des bouffées de
chaleur elle devait dire [ __ ] il ému
quand même et je me suis évanoui et je
me suis réveillée j'étais dans un bloc
opératoire et on opérait d'appendicite
je n'ai rien contre mon physique mais
mais c'est mon physique qui doit avoir
quelque chose contre moi
certes j'ai dit beaucoup de conneries
mais j'en ai produite aussi pas mal hein
je suis très bien sûr tu es affamés mais
c'est pas ce soir que tu vas me faire
dire du mal de la chaîne sur laquelle je
travaille
ils savent que tu es là tf1 oui oui il
ya eu comme une rumeur
et alors ils l'ont bien après je suis
sûr non parce qu ils savent que je ne
dis jamais une malle de de tf1 je
n'apprécie pas trop l'émission de cauet
mais alors je t'ai dit que j'ai une
otite ou pas
j'adore franck dubosc mai mais je crois
que je suis pas le seul la télévision
c'est une grande famille mais mais dans
toutes les familles il est toujours à un
oncle qui pue
une tante qui piquent et 1 et un cousin
un peu attardé coifferait patrick le lay
volé quoi que je fasse enfin vous avez
des soucis avec eux non franchement fin
pas dire valeurs à acheter
j'aime bien j'aime bien les émissions
j'ai présenté mais mais mais à peut-être
une ou deux si c'était à refaire je leur
fais pas lesquelles nice people
ah oui j'étais pas à l'aise dans son
émission pourquoi t'as fait ça parce
qu'elle en avait non tu sais laurent
c'est moche ce que tu fais parce que ce
que je t'ai pas dit c'est que j'ai avec
tout l'argent que j'ai décidé de
produire des jeunes artistes au cinéma
et en boîte le clac et tamponné on bouge
pas on en a des idées de films aguirre
mais attention tu sais qu'avec moi les
six marches à attendre laurent tu veux
quoi carton jaune carton rustre ans
arthur je ne suis peut-être pas le
meilleur animateur du monde mais ça
m'empêche pas de dormir
ouais évidemment david et l'idée mieux
que moi mais
mais d'abord c'est vrai mais ça fait des
progrès en beau gocité mais mais à oui
je sais où j'ai c'est vrai beaucoup de
boulot on a connu la la la qu'est ce que
je peux répondre à ça mais mais c'est
moi que estelle a choisi ouais c'est la
façon élégante de dire je suis jalouse
mais je saurai attendre que le petit
bébé de mixa bébé les 18 ans pour lui
péter sa gueule celui qui est toujours
lové dans les salles ma femme et je ne
peux marcher tout ça c'est pas dans le
spectacle non non non c'était début du
spectacle
non non non non non je me suis promis de
ne pas faire de boue du spectacle ah
d'accord
je ne serai jamais daniel ducruet mai
mais c'est pas grave
non j'ai une vraie star chez les gays
c'est vrai mais mais pas que chez eux
chez les phases aussi c'est que je suis
je comme il le fait j'ai tricard dans le
marais j'ai une toute petite [ __ ] mais
mais c'est parce que tu es très très
loin c'est parce que tu les vois de très
très loin
j'adore votre émission entière aimé mais
en tant que producteur et j'aurais
changé des petits trucs
ah ouais ouais il l'aurait mise le
dimanche soir vous vous souvenez de
giscard d'estaing oui je sais pas s'ils
se souvient de moi oui mais oui mais il
faut répondre oui mais ouais enfin nous
avons 8 mai alors je ne suis peut-être
pas le meilleur comique du monde mais
mais
je regarde les cassettes de jean roucas
pour m'améliorer c'est ça le principe
voilà d'accord je ne ferai pas comique à
la télé toute ma vie mais mais tant que
je ferai de la télé j'essaierai de
rester comique l'esprit canal n'est pas
mort mais il était temps que j'arrive ça
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai j'aime
bien la nouvelle émission de michel
denisot mais mais le vrai spectacle sur
canal démarre le vendredi soir stéphane
bern et franchement drôle mais mais
personnes se rencontrent
je ne suis pas méchant mais mais je
je progresse j'ai pas toujours été très
élégant avec mes invités mais aussi à
enrico garde ses mac os x le orlando la
kiss à orlando
orlando ne faut pas dire de mal de lui
c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui
oui oui il a 87 ans bon après c'est moi
qui me le tap au mathis et après pendant
des soirées entières
c'est stéphane guillon je ne veux plus
que tout la même vitesse des familles en
tape au mathis et s'avèrent vains c'est
une façon de gérer le voit maintenant
que l'europe a truqué soyons précis
chaque emploi si je suis pas raciste
mais mais j'essaye de lettres s'est
passé du boulot c'est ce que je vis dans
un beau quartier où ma voiture et dans
un garage qui fait donc c'est difficile
d'être facile quand on a aussi progressé
moi j'aimerais jeu plaît beaucoup aux
femmes mais je suis l'homme d'une seule
femme
c'est vrai je fais beaucoup aux hommes
mais mais amanda lear s'est toujours
refusé à moi j'aime bien monter sur
scène mais je préfère le vin peut rideau
jeu très ambitieux mais mais pas au
point de changer de coiffure pour piquer
la place de berne
je suis pas de droite mais je suis pas
de droite mais j'aime bien ségolène
royal
j'aime bien les gens mais j'aime bien
les gens surtout jean rochefort jean
rochefort
merci au président tout de suite on voi
le mec on voi le mec qui fait de la
scène tu vois il a l'habitude des
charges sur les bills et tout faire du
cinéma c'est bien mais mais sur les
dinos ont fait un four benjamin castaldi
est un gros naze mais mais il a des
goûts musicaux trait sur ces rotors
cette interview je ne suis pas une sex
machine mais mais
la plastique de ma femme me fait
démarrer au quart de tour j'suis veulent
et comme un dieu mais mais je reste
discret j'ai blessé une fois rocco
siffredi
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais pris de drogue mais mais
c'est une scène et à une conduite quoi
un comportement on est plusieurs à
l'avoir il ya doc gynéco il ya florent
pagny il ya moi il ya yannick noah on
est on est un petit groupe
je suis pas une [ __ ] mais mais cette
année à cannes a lui augmenté mais tape
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus